the jurogan experience but
there's some sports like let's look at
uh power lifting yes
or let's look at bodybuilding
bodybuilding's the best one yeah that
doesn't exist
it doesn't exist what do you mean
bodybuilding doesn't exist
oh right bodybuilding steroids exists by
regular bodybuilding
like um i had a friend uh my friend
brian uh who
lived in boston was a natural
bodybuilder and he was very dedicated
and he was like legitimate natural
bodybuilder he worked out very hard
he was a he ate very clean and he was
like super super dedicated and you would
swear he was on steroids he was big
i mean like big giant arms like really
thick guy
but just really dedicated he is
nothing like those giants that you see
at the gym that are on steroids
there are people that walk around like
if you go to like a gold's gym in venice
in in the heyday when all the elite
bodybuilders would go there
they don't even look like humans they
look like walls with feet
i saw it i went to a bodybuilding
competition in vegas for the show where
we were following this kid
who was mostly not doing steroids at
this time and like your friend he was
trying to see if he could make it into
this competition without
the heavy use of or heavily using
steroids and other
uh pd's and uh it was he went on stage
and you could see the difference between
him and the other guys i mean everybody
else there was heavily using people
and then you'd see him we actually
followed him we were with this guy
called tony huge who calls himself tony
tony huge
have you heard of this guy no he's
pretty incredible crazy he has a huge
following a huge following
yeah and he calls himself dr tony huge
even though he's not a doctor but he is
a lawyer
and he's if anyone wants is interested
in
he's basically a spokesperson for
steroids he's
people who are bodybuilders he's also a
bodybuilder himself and goes to gyms and
competitions and he was with this kid
and the kids adore him i mean we spoke
to teenagers who look up to tony huge
and want to do everything he does
which is mostly pd's and this kid wanted
to
be he went to vegas to help this kid out
and in the middle of
he was like 19 i believe his name's zach
from
florida super nice kid met his mom all
of it
uh but had had had tried steroids and
had sort of a bad experience with
steroids decided he was going to try and
do it with other things but not steroids
not testosterone itself but other
substances
tony huge was helping him out he gets
there dave of the competition he goes on
stage and again
he looks like the others around him who
have been doing steroids look
so much stronger than him and he comes
out yet you know again
super dedicated kid like this is his
life spends most of his time at the gym
and eats right and all that
and in the middle of the competition
tony huge says okay it's time for us to
go back to your apartment and get you
ready for round two
they go back and we filmed all of this
and he opens up a big suitcase and
inside this suitcase it's like the mary
poppins suitcase that
more and more shit's coming out you know
and and
starts giving him injections of insulin
and all sorts i don't know half of the
things that he was giving
and the kid's like are you sure this is
okay are you sure this is okay
and uh and i'm worried for him he says
okay i'm starting to feel my heart
beating really fast
uh you know you don't don't you worry
and then he goes back and you could
actually see the transformation in this
kid's body within
an hour of him taking these drugs i am
not what is the transformation what
happened
his uh uh vessels his blood veins
muscularity
yes we're popping his veins so that's
something good apparently for
these kind of competitions you're funny
the way you talk that's something good
apparently
i know that's my first time at a
bodybuilding competition for sure it's
weird it's so weird
when you see those people in real life
yeah i love we think worlds that look
nothing like what i'm used to i'm so
fascinated by them
i was watching a video last night on
vice of a woman
who uh does uh bodybuilding she's my
height
and my weight she weighed 196 pounds
and so and she has like her neck
is like my neck but her traps are even
bigger than mine they start like
here they go straight down her shoulders
were massive
and she was talking like this this is
what i eat
yeah this is uh every morning i have to
consume six thousand cows she sounded
like the rock
yeah like it was crazy bizarre it was so
bizarre
it was so strange to see this weird
obsess
it's they're like sculptors right
and in a way it is kind of an art form
totally
but what they're doing is freakish but
they're all into it
they'll all love it yeah this tony huge
guy um i actually kind of grew very fond
of him
just because he's so honest about what
he does i don't think his message is
very safe for
kids you know especially and you know
taking steroids you know the side
effects you have to be careful but yet
him saying you know i am basically uh a
human experiment on myself and i'm
trying all these things and
is there videos of him can we see what
he looks like this tony huge fail right
do you look ridiculous he's gonna love
this oh tony
oh no he actually doesn't look
ridiculous he's like yeah with tony tony
here
well there's a guy who's uh who died
recently
who was famous for looking ridiculous
his name was rich piana
do you know who that is i remember when
i was doing research for this story yeah
um
they don't exactly know if steroids
killed them
but it's like you know if you see a body
and then there's a gun right next to the
body like and the gun
the body has a bullet hole oh he's
pretty big yeah
he's big yeah but he's tiny compared to
rich piana no yeah
yeah oh he looks very good yeah see he
doesn't look preposterous
he looks like a a very big strong guy
like right there with a shirt off
picture
still he looks great like that's that is
a guy who's in very good shape
yeah doctor so he says okay this is uh i
used to be handsome this is maybe six or
seven years ago when i was 31 or 32 i
was still full-time
laura wearing a suit going to court
meeting clients
so yeah so that is he decided to start
taking steroids that's when he decided
is that what it says
okay so that that can be achieved
naturally that absolutely can be
achieved naturally especially with good
genetics
and that's uh one of the things that i
had do you know who ronnie coleman is
no ronnie coleman's if there's a
mount rushmore of bodybuilding he's on
it 100 it's like arnold
franco colombo lee haney
i mean how many mount rushmore doesn't
have enough heads
right dorian yates but ronnie coleman is
without doubt on there he's a multiple
time mr olympia
enormous guy yeah with spectacular
genetics
spectacular genetics and ronnie did the
podcast and he said that
when he was he's really in rough shape
now like he can barely walk his back is
really [ __ ] up he's had many many
surgeries
and he's basically had every disc in his
back fused except for one
and uh has a really hard time walking
and even standing up
but when but that's because you know he
pushed himself so hard so it wasn't just
the steroids
he pushed himself through pain so when
he got injured he didn't give a [ __ ] he
just kept working out hard and stacking
weights and
you know squatting spectacular amounts
of weight
but he was i believe he said he was 30
before he took steroids
so he was a full-time cop and uh he was
competing with just like
i mean perfect genetics just perfect i
mean he's just a stud
and then realized he couldn't beat these
guys no there's no way to get his ass
kicked and so then he got on
like he had uh that's when he wanted
when he was a cop
you get pulled over by that guy yes sir
here's license
sir sir don't squeeze my head like a zit
he's uh just a really sweet guy too an
awesome guy but
he was very honest about it he's like i
couldn't compete i was tired to get my
butt
my butt kicked right and then he started
taking it so in the usc it's not allowed
now no no no no no no no a lot of people
get busted
they get busted for trace amounts that
are
in supplements catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience